d'accord
peut-être que si nous allions bas ou sur le
côté gauche puis que nous nous élevions par-dessus le mur, nous
verrions que l'eau sur la droite
était plus haute ouais ouais ouais
promoteur d'enregistrement on se rapproche tu
enregistres ici hein je suis là
peut couper et changer maintenant la
valeur de votre
cadre
pour changer un peu
nous le reflammons
hé euh
avant d'arriver à euh
je vois le point bas il y a une rivière
qui sort ici
eh bien tu devrais couper quelqu'un d'autre
bonjour arrête
ça ressemble à un [ __ ]
euh
la petite route ici aussi
c'est trop présent
ce chemin de terre ici
on a l'impression que c'est le
sujet du de l'
image on bouge juste un peu vers la
droite
vers la droite
main droite cercle
et retour
ah y'a un cercle à droite  entourez le
pont c'est la sortie du euh
autour de lui s'il vous plaît arrêtez d'enregistrer
et nous devrions terminer à la fin avec le
avec une inclinaison
sur le euh
eh bien
je voudrais faire un blanc juste faire un grand
angle plus large un autre un autre cercle
s'il vous plaît  ok oui
c'est ça ouais  il raconte vers le
tu connais l'horizon et le sous ce
clic arrête l'enregistrement
étranger
bien fait et il faut le faire maintenant